hey everyone I'm Abbi chef welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's review is
sponsored by Squarespace and we're gonna
be looking at
Cassie ho from the popular YouTube
channel Blogilates now if you're not
only you're a Squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store or use their
marketing tools in analytics as a
blogger myself I love that Squarespace
has a number of SEO tools to really take
the guesswork out of making your site
Google friendly and it also has
appointment scheduling tools for online
booking or coordinating calendars I also
obviously do a lot of social media so
bloggers will really find the social
sharing buttons helpful while also
setting up email campaigns for mailing
lists when everything in your digital
presence works together like this it
makes it so much easier for you to focus
on your actual business you can check
out squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com slash Abby sharp to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain okay so now let's get on to
Cassie if you're not familiar Cassie
there's a lot of ground to cover this
video was heavily requested by all of
you after a lot of you felt kind of
triggered by Cassie's how to tell if
it's hunger versus a cravings Instagram
and tik-tok video we'll be doing a deep
dive into that later I also know Cassie
has a long complicated history of being
painted as both a body-positive
influencer and the poster child of diet
culture so I did want to explore that a
bit as well this video will not be a
traditional what I in a day review
though we will see some meal reviews but
I mainly want to answer your question on
whether or not Cassie can be a body
positive influencer and still want to
lose weight and whether you can be body
positive and lose weight as well of
course Before we jump in to my review I
want to start with my general disclaimer
that the information in this video is
for entertainment and educational
purposes only and you should always seek
out the help of a registered dietitian
or medical professional for your
unique needs also a trigger warning that
I will be talking about weight loss
numbers and also a reminder to please be
kind to both me and Cassie in the
comments now let's start with a little
bit of a history on Cassie's content
back in 2015
Cassie posted the now viral video called
the perfect body where she discussed
some of the horrible fad phobic comments
that she would get on her channel that
really questioned her ability as a
trainer because she didn't have a
six-pack or prominent ass at its core
the video was a powerful response to the
assumption that one's body and looks
determined their Worth and success in
their job this is such a hugely
problematic assumption so of course I'm
happy to hear Cassie address it in such
a powerful shareable format now in
response Cassie was labeled as a body
positive poster-child a title that was
totally turned upside down when she
announced her 90 day weight loss journey
last August now in her video how I lost
seventeen point five pounds in 12 weeks
Cassie described embarking on a wellness
journey to get herself into the best
shape of her life both physically and
mentally
according to her this meant doing more
workouts that she actually enjoyed like
dancing cooking for herself because
would bring her joy and blogging
everyday to null it others opinion of
her sensor her true self all of that
sounds great and obviously well aligned
with body positivity gentle nutrition
joyful movement and body kindness but
then she also announced specific number
goals for her weight and body fat and
that's kind of where people lost their
so what did her journey look like well
Cassie described working out six days a
week doing a combination of running
Pilates hit dancing and weight lifting
she basically said her workouts actually
didn't change that much from what she
was doing before but she did throw
dancing into the mix which she said she
loved for stress release and fun which
to me is really a great example of
joyful movement it doesn't sound like
she was made
whose help totally miserable to ramp up
her activity so that to me is a great
sign and well aligned with body
positivity food however is where she
obviously made the most changes to meet
her goals she started off doing what she
calls lazy Kido okay
not counting macros or calories per se
but just focusing on eating lots of fat
she even describes this phase of her
diet as being fun which is great I mean
we want food
to be fun but after she hit a weight
loss plateau she decided to cut out
cheese and nuts which is where it kind
of sounds like the fun diet ended for
her if we're talking body positivity and
intuitive eating and how that intersects
with weight loss diets I would have to
say that if you are having to remove
foods from your diet that you enjoy
specifically in response to weight loss
plateaus it's probably not an intuitive
way to eat
she also describes getting on and off
doubts of keto flu which is a series of
symptoms including headaches fatigue
dizziness and digestive distress that
come on as your body tries to adapt to
running on ketones instead of glucose
the keto diet especially at the
beginning can cause severe shifts and
electrolytes and fluids as most of the
weight lost at the beginning is largely
water weight so this explains why she
started to feel better after she
increased her salt intake but she
ultimately came to the conclusion that
if keto required her to do all of these
extra things just to feel normal
it wasn't the diet for her so she
switched back to a more typical way of
eating for her with more fruit and less
fats and not surprisingly her key to flu
symptoms went away I want to say that I
do think even in the context of weight
loss this is a good example of
collecting data about how food makes you
feel and making adjustments based on
what does and does not feel good so I am
happy to hear that she abandoned
something that just didn't feel right
for her body next she talks about
hitting another weight loss plateau
which was when she decided to start
calorie counting using MyFitnessPal
according to Cassie tracking her
calories gave her mental space to
breathe because she wasn't needing to
calculate the numbers in her head all
the time now I know I have criticized
calorie counting in the past but I do
get a lot of feedback from you guys that
for some of you calorie counting may
help you feel less obsessive about what
you eat and this may be because you
don't have to constantly worry about
whether or not a food or meal is
supporting or negating your weight loss
goals eliciting excess and unnecessary
food guilt I mean obviously I would
argue that we don't need to feel guilty
or worry regardless that you know our
bodies are a lot smarter than an app if
we were to just tune into them but I
also know that not everyone is at that
stage in their intuitive eating journey
now in terms of weight loss research has
shown that counting calories can support
weight loss goals as it does provide an
easy way to kind of self monitor intakes
however it's really important to note
that not all calories are created equal
foods that may have the same caloric
quantity may be vastly different in
terms of their nutritional quality and
therefore have different impacts on your
overall health satiety satisfaction and
how you feel for example if you eat just
fruits and vegetables you probably take
in fewer calories than had you added in
some tofu or nut butter or whole-grain
bread but you also may not feel
emotionally satisfied or physically
satiated and instead might be left
feeling really bloated and fatigued not
to mention you wouldn't be getting a
wide variety of nutrients that you need
for your body to thrive so listening to
only these external cues like the
information on a MyFitnessPal app can
easily over I've a lot of important
information from your unique body having
said all that if counted calories is
something that works for you and your
goals I mean that's totally great
but in my books calories are not King
and are not more important than balanced
variety and the internal messages that
your body is giving you now Cassie also
discusses Wing
herself daily to keep herself honest and
give herself something to objectively
work towards interestingly at one point
Cassie even acknowledged that she hadn't
stepped on a scale for a few years
before that because of the way it would
affect her emotionally likely because of
her history with orthorexia so let's see
what she has to say about her past
disordered eating experience so back in
2012 I entered bikini competition and
got down to 113 pounds because I was
eating around a thousand calories a day
plus I was working out four hours a day
doing intense weight lifting so my body
was totally depleted okay now I want to
hop in here with some thoughts on using
the scale and specific numeric goals
especially in the context of past
disordered behaviors and thoughts like
basically what Cassie is describing now
the scale is just one tool so I'm not
against using it if it doesn't trigger
you and and your appraisal of yourself
but as we know when our self
consistently can become a real obsession
if it's the only tool that you're using
to gauge how you feel or your progress
this is particularly true for people
that have a history of disordered eating
so I would have just been concerned that
this would be really triggering for
Cassie daily weigh-ins is not something
that I generally recommend period but
especially for people with body
dysmorphia or a disordered eating
but according to Cassie she has since
retrained her brain to get out of the or
3x6 state of mind and was able to shift
towards a journey of self-love
regardless of if that meant losing
weight or gaining weight in her words
she says she appreciates her body for
what it can do and is grateful for it
regardless of its size now I think that
this sentiment is amazing and ultimately
what body kindness is about but then my
question is why the need to set specific
body weight and body fat goals if there
was an equal appreciation of one's
weight going up or going down I think
this is where the lines get a little bit
tied for some of her followers and I'm
going to explore that
more details soon now cassie also
describes the daily weigh-ins as a
clinical data collection and pointed out
that there were naturally a lot of ups
and downs which is to be expected as our
daily body weight is constantly
fluctuating as a result of things like
menstruation dehydration caffeine and
alcohol consumption sodium intake and
bowel movements hence why I don't think
that the scale is the best tool for
daily progress anyways but if we are
going to use it we would definitely be
wanting to look more overall patterns
and not absolute daily numbers now while
I myself am a bit confused by the mixed
messaging that we have you know having
clear weight targets and simultaneously
saying that you're on a journey of
self-love regardless of what the scale
says it's ultimately not my place to
judge if particular actions are done
from a place of self-care or body
distrust so if this all felt good to
Cassie and the experiment resulted in
some net benefit to her physically and
emotionally then all the power to her
now what was the result
trigger warning here folks I'm gonna
talk numbers
now within 90 days cassie lost seventeen
point four pounds which is 13% of her
body weight and 3.6 percent of her body
fat the CDC recommends losing no more
than one to two pounds per week which is
not beyond what Cassie lost but I would
say that with a starting weight already
in the normal BMI category at 13 percent
loss in three months is pretty drastic
as for her body fat she landed herself
at twenty point eight percent body fat
which had her straddling the athletic
and fitness categories for body fat now
typically for most women twenty percent
is still high enough to maintain normal
hormonal patterns and menstruation but
ultimately everyone has their own
fertile weight and body fat percentage
and according to amenorrhea expert dr.
nicola Rinaldi the specific body fat
percentage is less of an issue for
hormone regulation and regular
menstruation then the caloric deficit
needed to achieve that so Cassie noted
that the
wish that she would eat was around 1200
calories and that fluctuated based on
what she was eating that day or what she
felt like but considering her activity
level my calculations put her needs at
closer to 2,100 calories as an average
per day even with her goal of weight
loss in mind she also said that because
her calories were not too low that she
never experienced starvation mode or
adaptive thermogenesis which is
essentially when your metabolism slows
down to compensate for getting an
inadequate amounts of fuel but it's
really important to point out that you
can experience metabolic adaptation or
slowed metabolism at caloric intakes
well above 1200 calories so what was
enough for Cassie's body may not be
enough for you it's also really hard to
know if your body has really been
through metabolic adaptation or suffered
metabolic damage until you go off the
diet and I'm not entirely sure if this
way of eating was something that she's
just kind of maintained now that we have
that background err let's now move to
discuss some of the reasons why a lot of
you are confused about Cassie stance
when it comes to body positivity and
weight loss first things first I want to
take a look at her tic TOCs an Instagram
post beginning with a couple quickie
what ain't a days that she shared on her
feed let's take a look
okay excuse the wardro change here folks
my mic apparently cut out so I had to
reshoot this little wee bit here but
anyways in response to these two days as
she's shared even though we are seeing a
lot of lower carb alternatives like
cauliflower rice and jicama wraps and
paleo bread because she's got a good
amount of fruit in here we actually have
a generally good balance of fat protein
and carbs there's even a little ice
cream in there for good measure
now the calories are moderately low I
would say around 1300 calories on both
days but we already knew that that was
Cassie's approximate caloric goals based
on her kind of 90-day journey other than
the fact that like I said I think the
calories are generally a bit low even
for weight loss given her activity level
there isn't anything inherently super
restrictive about these meals if this is
what feels good to Cassie and
considering that she herself suggested
that she feels better
eating a lot of fruit it does sound like
she's just kind of listening to her body
with these meals I'll be it maybe
perhaps with some caloric restrictions
as regulated by her MyFitnessPal app I
didn't hear her mention that she feels
really hungry or restricted eating this
way so I am just really hoping that this
level of restriction is not an
uncomfortable experience for her next
let's get into some of the explicit diet
tips that I've been sent from a lot of
you guys on Instagram and tik-tok
sometimes I get so bloated but I'm going
to show you guys what I eat to go from
this to this in just a few days the most
important thing is that you stay
hydrated so I make lemon water with a
ton of ice and I drink at least 64
ounces throughout the day meal one is a
vegetarian bowl over cauliflower rice
then I'll have a plate of berries as a
snack meal two is a plate of ground
turkey sweet potato
and cabbage my snap some fresh cut
watermelon meal 3 is salmon with collard
greens in zucchini and for dessert so
kombucha for healthy probiotics most
importantly give yourself time and don't
stress your body is resilient ok so I
can see where the tension lies within
the context of the body positive
movement as I mentioned in my video on
bloating often the phrase I feel so
bloated has become the socially
acceptable alternative to I feel so fat
likewise
getting rid of bloating is a less
controversial version of losing weight
that doesn't mean there aren't non diet
related messages out there related to
reducing bloating since let's be real
bloating can be physically uncomfortable
and can sometimes even be a sign that
something is physically wrong but it
often comes down to the specific
information that's being shared in
Cassie's case I do appreciate the
message in the copy of this post that
sometimes you want the churro so have
the churro and sometimes you'll bloat
and sometimes you won't
to me this is aligned with body kindness
and intuitive eating in that sometimes
we gather information that a particular
food doesn't make us feel so good but we
choose to eat it anyways because yellow
you know it feels good in other ways
whether that's emotionally culturally
socially etc but I don't love the line
that follows which was that your body
will heal itself when you eat
nutritiously again I mean to a lot of
viewers this may insinuate that you're
damaging your body by having a churro or
that your body is damaged if you don't
have a flat stomach like Cassie I also
find that a lot of wellness youtubers
kind of sandwich their diet culture
messages with anti diet messages like
give yourself time don't stress you're
resilient etc I don't think that was
necessarily Cassie's intention as I know
it's just so hard not to use language
that isn't inherently rooted in diet
culture I mean we're all guilty of doing
it even when we're actively trying not
to but I think we can all try a little
harder to reduce
this nuanced language to slowly change
how we talk about and think about our
bodies and food meanwhile for those
watching me right now I want all of you
to know right now that it's very normal
for your stomach to not be flat many
women will never have a completely flat
stomach and it's not because they didn't
have kombucha for dessert
in fact when I don't defer into Cassie's
videos I can't find another one on
bloating back in April that I felt had a
much more body positive message in it
she basically said what I just mentioned
and that was it is okay and totally
normal to be bloated once in a while
bloat isn't bad but it can hurt and be
extremely uncomfortable she also talks
about taking mental notes of what she's
eating how she's feeling and how it
affects her body all of this is
beautifully aligned with what I always
talk about when I say that intuitive
eating is all about collecting data and
I think this is a much more supportive
way to talk about bloating and digestion
in general as for the recommendations
itself I don't have any major issues
with Cassie's diet in this video if this
is what's working for her even though
let's be real 30 calorie kombucha is
delicious but it's not dessert but I do
want to flag that this is not a
foolproof diet to reduce bloating in one
to three days like her video suggests on
the positive side we've got lots of
water and water rich produce going in
which of course may help flush at excess
sodium which may be causing water
attention but on the flip side I'm not
sure I would recommend a lot of cabbage
or cauliflower rice for people who are
trying to devote as a lot of people find
that cruciferous vegetables can trigger
their gas and bloating also if you're
sensitive to FODMAPs and this is what's
causing your bloating foods like
watermelon cauliflower mushrooms some
cabbages blackberries avocado and even
kombucha are all - AB and therefore may
actually worsen the bloating problem the
carbonation in kombucha also probably
won't help
so bottom line while this diet may work
for Cassie for her
loading I would argue that these are not
universally recommended strategies for
bloating relief and may actually make
things worse for people who are
legitimately struggling with bloating
and other digestive issues and because
of the inconsistencies in the messaging
here I can't help but feel that these
meals are much more aligned with weight
loss tactics than anti bloating
recommendations again that maybe wasn't
Cassie's intention but I can see how is
easily read that way by her followers
and despite me seeing Cassie's effort to
separate herself from heavy dye culture
in this video I think for some viewers
the waters may still look a little murky
ok let's move on next I want to address
the video that clearly rubs you all the
wrong way as it's probably been DM to me
like 50 times and that video is how to
know if you're actually hungry versus
just craving let's take a look
well her video suggests that you do the
banana test to see if you're actually
hungry or if you're just having a food
craving and this is really just an
offshoot of the age-old diet culture
tactic formerly known as the Apple test
but I don't know I guess apples are out
of season but anyways according to
Cassie we should ask herself if a banana
sounds good to eat or if you only want a
burger or cookie and if you choose the
cookie or burger you're not actually
hungry but if you choose the banana go
eat I mean it's no wonder so many of you
sent me this clip in a panic in the copy
cassie talks about how she's just not an
intuitive ear you know she's an
emotional eater and that throughout her
90-day journey she was able to really
see how often she was mindlessly eating
and which emotions were triggering those
tendencies but here's the problem with
this test just because a banana doesn't
sound good to you right now does not
mean your body doesn't deserve fuel
hunger can be more nuanced and
multifaceted than just having an empty
belly so for example some people like to
differentiate between stomach mouths and
emotional hunger stomach hunger occurs
when we have a physiological need for
food to sustain our body functions we
can typically recognize stomach hunger
as our stomach growling or our energy
level dropping now mouth hunger is our
hunger for specific pleasurable
characteristics of food so for instance
we know that we're feeling mouths hunger
when we really are hungry first certain
taste texture or smell like honestly I
have basically had mouth hunger for
watermelon my entire pregnancy so
there's that now emotional hunger occurs
in response to how food makes us feel
emotionally and while diet culture and
this post of Cassie's would insinuate
that eating for any reason other than
stomach hunger is bad it's actually
really normal and healthy to eat for a
variety of reasons in fact sometimes all
three of these hungers are occurring at
once desiring a particular food because
satisfies an emotional need or a flavor
desire really needs to be more
normalized in the wellness community if
it was we would probably be able to be
more likely to enjoy a piece of
celebrity cake and move on
rather than spiraling into a guilt cycle
that results in us polishing off the
entire cake when we eat out of emotional
or mouth hunger the key is to
acknowledge it move on and not let the
emotionally eaten piece of cake dictate
your attitude towards your body yourself
or your next meal so emotional eating is
not inherently bad or abnormal but when
it becomes our only coping mechanism
that is when we may need to do some
reflection to understand why that is now
another way of thinking about this is to
differentiate between physical satiety
and emotional satisfaction which I've
talked about in this video right here
the problem is that if these two things
are not well aligned we often go pantry
surfing until we get what we actually
need a banana may satisfy our physical
hunger but not be emotionally satisfying
so we might eat the banana feel a little
bit more satiated then we eat the rice
cakes
the baked chips the diet ice cream and a
bag of jerky desperately searching for
the satisfaction that we crave meanwhile
maybe a burger would have satisfied both
our need for satiety and satisfaction
and we could have just moved on with our
day thankfully after a lot of public
backlash from this post kasi updated the
post to clarify that she didn't mean you
should never have a cookie or burger and
if you make that conscious choice to eat
dessert do it own it and enjoy it so I
am hoping that she got the memo on why
this test could do more harm than good
it is still up on her Instagram so I
don't know maybe that's just wishful
thinking and before her copyedit on the
post I would say that this post was
marked pretty heavily with diet culture
rhetoric and it's not surprising and
resulted in so much public
disappointment and outcry next I want to
look at some other content we've seen on
Cassie's channel and how these pieces of
content paint Cassie's
for evolving brand first let's look at
her research on Fitness influencer
beauty standards now in a video called
the unusual beauty standard for Fitness
girls
Cassie does a pretty cool analysis of
the top fitness influencers and how they
compare to other influencers and also
the average woman not surprisingly top
Fitness influencers have a look of being
largely white with prominent abs and
around ass and Cassie wonders how much
greater her following would be if she
maybe fit this mold well I do think this
cultural analysis is super interesting I
can see how it might be interpreted as a
little off first of all I can appreciate
the pressure that Fitness influencers
feel to look a certain way that this
idealized body is nearly impossible for
most women to attain but at one point
cassie talks about being proud that she
was in the top 100 Fitness influencers
list despite having this body I think
it's a bit tone-deaf to refer to her
body as this body when she still looks
nothing like the average American woman
likely ever will
she even pointed out herself that the
average American woman is the size 16 to
18 and while I don't know what size she
wears it's definitely not size 16 she
may be a visible minority and I think
that we need a lot more of that in the
fitness world but just because she
didn't have a six-pack before her
challenge doesn't mean that her body is
not an example of ideal and otherwise
unattainable for 99.9% of her followers
so while I do appreciate Cassie using
her analytical and evidence-based mind
to do a deep dive on this topic I think
the point would have gotten across a lot
better if she had profiled some awesome
of Fitness influencers who actually
looked like the average North American
woman or poor in larger bodies so people
like Louisa from curvy girl meets yoga
Jesse from curves with moves and rods
from rasa diva yes the fitness industry
needs a lot more diversity so let's
promote that but yeah this one to me
economists the body-positive mark
next let's talk about her body love
challenge now in her February video
called
don't like your body this video will
change that cassie promotes a Pilates
retreat that she was the post host this
summer which I assume is no longer
happening thanks to Kovan as part of the
marketing for this piece she promotes
the body love challenge which suggests a
handful of daily exercises to promote a
healthy relationship with your body and
mind exercises like name one amazing
thing that your body lets you do or name
five things that you love about your
body are all strategies that I have
talked about before as part of the
intuitive eating series and I love that
they take the focus away from how our
body looks towards what our body
actually does research suggests that
self affirmations like these can
actually reduce stress and improve
health promoting behaviors like eating
more fruits and vegetables so yes they
actually work I do have to say that if
this is the type of information that
would have been passed around at the
Pilates retreat it's really too bad that
it isn't happening but regardless I
would at least say that the sentiment
behind the body love challenge is a
supportive one that we definitely just
need to see a lot more of now I want to
discuss the response video cassie posted
in the wake of the pushback that she got
on her 90-day journey entitled the
complicated world of body positivity I
admittedly loved this video because I'm
a total history geek and she even talks
to the body-positive founder Connie sobs
AK plus two plus sized models I was so
happy that Cassie specifically said that
she want in feud larger bodied women who
had a different lived experience than
her because it was important to hear
their voices but anyways in this video
she largely focuses on how body
positivity has become a marketing ploy
for a lot of major brands and how even
body-positive brands discriminate by
hiring largely women who are white have
an hourglass figure with thin necks and
faces and high cheekbones as modeling
agent Chelsea Bonner said you're allowed
to be curvy as long as you have a really
tiny waist and no cellulite it's a
that the fashion industry has co-opted
this movement for financial gain but of
course I'm not surprised now the video
then explores both sides of the argument
on whether or not you can be
body-positive
and want to lose weight and after
discussing both sides of the argument
Cassie comes to the conclusion that how
you answer this question ultimately
really depends on how you define body
positivity and the thing is there is no
one agreed-upon definition so I thought
that I would throw my own ring into the
hat and answer the question can you be
body positive and want to lose weight
like Cassie said it starts with the
definition and to me body positivity at
its core is a belief that all bodies
regardless of their size shape sexual
orientation color etc are worthy bodies
being body positive is about giving
yourself permission to love take
pleasure and provide self-care to your
body even as it changes throughout the
lifecycle for a lot of advocates of the
fat liberation movement a desire to lose
weight is inherently at odds with body
positivity because it highlights
societal fat phobia if being fat wasn't
so bad why would we want to shrink our
bodies so badly but as I discussed in my
video right here
I personally believe in a more nuanced
approach the same way that I think
eating a lot of kale salads and
smoothies can be seen as either healthy
or orth or x'q wanting to lose weight
can be potentially against or aligned
with body positivity I think it really
comes down to intention and actual
behaviors to understand your intention I
would start by asking yourself why do I
want to lose weight and what am I
willing to do to lose it if you want to
lose weight to look more attractive and
are willing to participate in
restrictive diets and punishing exercise
regimes that interfere with your quality
of life then I would argue that that may
not be body-positive but if you want to
lose weight so that you can physically
or mentally feel better move better or
have a better quality of life and the
behaviors that you're taking inherently
feel good to you
then this maybe body-positive I want a
flag that I'm not shaming women like
Cassie for having aesthetic goals I mean
we are an aesthetic driven culture so
it's almost impossible to resist the
desire to look a certain way especially
in the fitness industry but it's worth
at least acknowledging these societal
pressures and what chasing these goals
may mean for a general health and
happiness so if the journey of losing
weight is an act of self-love and
finding health and happiness is the
ultimate goal with weight loss being
just one variable that may or may not
occur then yes I absolutely think that
this is compatible with body positivity
I believe that for a lot of people
health can be achieved without weight
loss and for others perhaps it can't
fully that's not really for me to
determine for each individual it's also
not appropriate for me to determine some
kind of cutoff weight or BMI where it's
okay for one person to want to lose
weight but it's not okay for another I
mean what is that arbitrary number
obviously a lot of people would look at
Cassie in her pre 90-day journey state
and say she was healthy then she didn't
need to lose weight but again I am
learning that tearing women down for
being at different points in their body
positive journey is not helping the
problem it doesn't change the societal
pressures it just shames women for being
too powerless to overcome them so does
Cassie's purposeful weight-loss make her
anti-body positive well first of all I
want a flag that it sounds like Cassie
never wanted to be a spokesperson for
the body positive movement she just made
a video largely about her experience
with online bullying in her industry it
went viral and suddenly she was given a
status that she probably didn't expect
second I can see why there's been a lot
of pushback because the public branded
Cassie has a body-positive ally and
depending on how body positivity is
defined a lot of people may see her
90-day journey as being inherently
anti-body positive but I'm beginning to
appreciate that none of us can really
ever know what is body positive to
another person
looking at Cassie's content as I did in
this video I do see a lot of diet
culture messages intertwined between
body positive or body kindness messages
I can see why that's confusing for a lot
of you but my take is that Cassie is
clearly on a journey and because she's a
public person she's on a very public
journey and these journeys are rarely
linear even for myself I am still
learning and trying to find my crystal
clear message and voice but I know that
will always change as I evolve and grow
and that's a good thing in my opinion
it's also so hard not to get sucked into
diet culture because these messages are
just so pervasive it's really easy for
our diet culture roots to show and for
these problematic statements to slip out
even despite our best intentions and as
an influencer it's also easy to give in
to public pressure and while body
positivity is having a bit of a moment
right now
it's nothing compared to the
overwhelming public interest in how to
look smaller or how to lose weight so in
conclusion if Cassie's content isn't
supporting your body positive journey
right now there are a lot of other great
influencers whose message is more direct
so I'm definitely going to leave a link
to some my favorites below and if you to
feel troubled by the push and pull to
love your body while simultaneously
wanting to lose weight my advice is to
focus on what is working for you and no
one else if weight loss is what feels
good to you and help support your
physical and mental health you do you
and if staying the weight you are even a
society says you shouldn't is supporting
your well-being that's great too
do not let anyone or anything including
the unfortunate public backlash against
Cassie's journey inform what is best for
you and on that note a big reminder to
please be kind in the comments both to
myself and to Cassie I would love to
know how you define body positivity and
if you think you can be body positive
and want to lose weight so definitely
leave me a comment below and of course
another big thank you to Squarespace
sponsoring this video if you liked it
don't forget to give it the thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you